si gana el rechazo como aparentemente
estaría pasando evidentemente
lo mejor que podría pasar en ese
escenario es que se avance en un proceso
para hacer una nueva constitución
bien sea modificando la del 80 o tomando
algunas cosas de este proyecto
constitucional no obstante ahí hay un
espacio de tiempo entre hoy que se sepa
el resultado si es que gana el rechazo y
el momento en el cual se vaya a tener
una nueva constitución en ese lapso de
tiempo me parece que lo lógico desde el
punto de vista jurídico es que la
constitución vigente es la de 1980 eso
va a generar una un problema político y
social creo yo muy grande porque el
rechazo a la constitución del 80 es
parte de lo que llevó a tener la
asamblea o la convención constitucional
que terminó su trabajo y presentó esta
nueva propuesta entonces se pregunta a
uno
chile listo para mantener en vigencia y
en operación y en implementación la
constitución de 1980 por unos meses o
años más mientras se tiene un nuevo
texto constitucional va a ser lo
suficientemente tolerante resistente y
resiliente para poder seguir ese proceso
bien sea que se haga a través del
congreso o con una nueva convención oa
través de un grupo de expertos en fin
que son las tesis que se han venido
lanzando sobre la mesa